herr professor jetzt noch einmal wie
gefährlich sind denn die masken nun im
basket sind das schild billig aber auch
nicht denn
die nasen rachen raum des träger ist das
heißt bevor sie in den mund nase oder an
den monarchen schütze angekommen sind
waren sie ja im mund oder im nasen
rachen raum dessen der die maske trägt
es sind also seine eigenen keime wenn er
keine maske trägt ja dann hatte diese
keime genau dieselben eben auch im
nasen-rachen-raum im mund und deswegen
ist das also ein ziemlicher unsinn dass
ich dort krankheitserreger ansammeln
können nicht einmal vermehren können
sich dort also man findet dort nur die
keime des trägers die er sowieso auch
hat
also sind diese keime nicht gefährlich
richtig sie sind absolut ungefährlich es
sind sogenannte physiologische keime die
jeder hat die zur mundflora gehören zum
mund und rachen floor gehört man könnte
fast sagen wenn man diese keime nicht
finden würde dann wäre es bedenklich
dann hat der träger vielleicht eine
krankheit oder irgendetwas gemacht er
braucht ja eine gewisse mundflora die
gehört der praktisch zur verdauung dazu
denn die mundflora leitet ja die
zersetzung der nahrung ein also das
gehört alles dazu also in ihren augen
was wäre jetzt der richtige schritt eine
masken pflicht bis für eine impfung
haben ja sie ja das wäre genau das
richtige denn jetzt endlich wird ja
immer wieder und völlig zu recht
behauptet oder nicht behauptet gesagt
achtung leute corona ist immer noch da
und es gibt schwere fälle
vielleicht auch nur 15 prozent und es
gibt leichte fälle von 85 oder 80
prozent aber wir wissen natürlich
niemals zu welchem prozentsatz wer jetzt
habe ge wird deswegen ist es natürlich
sinnvoll in gefährlichen situationen
oder sagen wir mal in situationen wo man
sich anstecken kann immer diese maske zu
tragen das heißt also u bahn s bahn bus
da wo viele menschen aufeinander treffen
im supermarkt an der kasse wo man warten
muss wo man zwischen anderen leuten
steht und nicht einen gebührenden
abstand hat da sollte man auf jeden fall
die maske tragen den mund nasenschutz
tagen
und solange keine eben von medikamenten
ist das sinnvoll
das wird hier im normalfall eigentlich
vielleicht ein zwei stunden wenn
überhaupt am tag der fall sein da wo man
auf menschen trifft muss man die maske
tragen da wo keine menschen sind oder
nur sehr wenige oder sie weiter wechselt
als 1 50 da braucht man die manns
gemischt